este vídeo le ayudará a comprender cómo
se controla la presión arterial en el
cuerpo
y la presión arterial es la cantidad de
fuerza causada por la sangre que ejerce
presión contra las paredes de las
arterias está minuciosamente controlada
para garantizar que llegue suficiente
sangre a todas las partes del cuerpo las
arterias son vasos sanguíneos que llevan
la sangre desde el corazón a los tejidos
esta sangre suministra a los tejidos el
oxígeno y los nutrientes necesarios para
funcionar en su corazón hay dos
cavidades inferiores denominadas
ventrículos que se contraen con cada
latido del corazón
el ventrículo derecho envía la sangre
con poco oxígeno a los pulmones para que
recojan oxígeno y el ventrículo
izquierdo envía la sangre rica en
oxígeno a través de las arterias a todo
el cuerpo a medida que la sangre fluye a
través de las arterias cuatro factores
principales afectan la presión de las
paredes arteriales el primero es la
cantidad de sangre que los ventrículos
sacan de su corazón cada minuto también
conocido como gasto cardíaco la presión
arterial sube a medida que el gasto
cardíaco aumenta
el segundo factor que afecta a su
presión arterial es la cantidad total de
sangre en el cuerpo o volumen de sangre
la presión arterial también se eleva a
medida que se incrementa el volumen
sanguíneo
el tercer factor que afecta a la presión
arterial es la resistencia la
resistencia es cualquier cosa que
trabaja contra el flujo sanguíneo a
través de sus arterias
la resistencia se ve principalmente
afectada por el ancho de las arterias el
cuerpo puede incrementar el ancho de las
arterias para disminuir la presión
arterial
o puedes reducir el ancho para elevar la
presión arterial
el cuarto factor que afecta a la presión
arterial es la viscosidad la viscosidad
se trata de cuan espesa es la sangre en
la sangre más partículas como proteínas
y grasas incrementan la viscosidad si la
sangre es más espesa la presión arterial
se eleva a medida que su corazón trabaja
más duro para empujarla a través de sus
arterias
si tiene preguntas acerca de la presión
arterial alta o cualquier medicamento
que le hayan recetado consulte con su
médico
es importante tomar los medicamentos
siguiendo las instrucciones e informar
acerca de cualquier efecto secundario
que pueda tener